aquí tenemos tres funciones esta función
f en color magenta esta función g en
este color verde y esta función a h con
esta línea punteada color violeta y aquí
tenemos tres potenciales expresiones
tres expresiones que podrían
corresponder a estas funciones lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es establecer
la correspondencia entre la gráfica y la
expresión de la función para empezar te
invito a que le pongas pausa al vídeo e
intentes hacerlo por tu cuenta antes de
que lo hagamos juntos hay un par de
maneras de hacer esto
la primera es hacer directamente la
gráfica de estas funciones y ver a cuál
de estas que tenemos aquí corresponde o
podemos a partir de las gráficas de las
funciones determinar cuáles son las asín
totas verticales y horizontales y ver
cuál de estas expresiones corresponde a
dichas assynt o estás no va a hacer de
la segunda manera viendo las gráficas
tiendo a ser más de visualizar las cosas
parece ser que f voy a empezar con f
parece ser que f tiene una sintética en
x 5 perdón en x igual a menos 5 entonces
f tiene una cinta vertical en x
5 ahora veamos cuál de estas tiene una
cinta vertical en x
5 recordemos que para que haya una sin
tota vertical la función no está
definida ahí y aún así tendríamos que
checar que efectivamente es una sin tota
vertical y no un hoyo una discontinuidad
puntual en la función así es que
revisemos las expresiones veamos esta
primera expresión si está definida en x
igual a menos 5 no estaría definida si
el denominador fuera 0 pero aquí vemos
que menos 5 menos 5 es igual a menos 10
si está definida para ese valor
así es que ésta no s t ésta también está
definida en x igual a menos 5 el
denominador no se hace 0 ésta tampoco es
f esta de aquí el denominador se hace
cero cuando x es igual a menos 5 así es
que por un razonamiento meramente
deductivo esta expresión es la única que
posiblemente es fx verifiquemos que es
consistente con otros elementos de la
gráfica chequemos lajas into estás
horizontales al ver la gráfica
observamos que aquí hay una sintonía son
tal cuando existiendo infinito cuando x
tiene
es cada vez más grandes fx tiende a 1 se
cumple eso para la expresión
a medida que x se hace cada vez más
grande a medida que existiendo infinito
entonces menos 2 y 5 ya no van a afectar
a medida que extiende infinito para
valores de x grandes esto se va a
aproximar a x sobre x los cuales son los
términos de mayor orden así es que esto
tiende a 1 restar 2 y sumar 5 restar 2
al numerador y sumar 5 al denominador no
afecta para nada cuando x es un número
que es cada vez más grande
así es que fx tiende a 1 f x es
consistente con la cinta horizontal hay
algún otro aspecto que podamos checar
bien cuando se hace de x igual a 0 esto
se cumple cuando el numerador es igual a
0 es decir cuando x es igual a 2 lo cual
se ve aquí en la gráfica estoy
satisfecho con esta fx veamos ahora que
x
gdx tiene una cinta vertical en x igual
a 5
aquí la tenemos la cinta está vertical
en x 5 pero espera aquí nos damos cuenta
que no nos sirve de mucho esta cinta
está vertical para discernir entre g y h
pues ambas tienen las into está vertical
en x 5 g y h ambas tienen asiento está
vertical en x igual a 5 y aquí lo puedes
ver cuando x igual a 5 ambos
denominadores se hacen 0 con lo cual
estas funciones no están definidas en x
igual a 5
veamos si la cinta horizontal nos puede
ayudar parece que tiene una sintonía
horizontal en ye igual a menos 2 en g
igual a menos 2 cuando x toma valores
negativos o positivos muy grandes head
se aproxima a menos 2 veamos qué sucede
con esta de arriba bien eliminando
paréntesis en el numerador esto va a ser
igual a 2x menos 12 sobre x menos 5
ahora cuando x es cada vez más grande ni
el menos 5 ni el menos 12 van a influir
cuando existiendo infinito esto va a ser
aproximadamente igual a 2x sobre x y
aquí voy a precisar esto para no mejoro
a poner como cuando x tiende a infinito
esto tiende a 2x sobre x y esto se
aproxima a 2 cuando x tiende a infinito
la función se aproxima 20 g de x se
aproxima a menos 2 en cambio vemos que
hdx cuando x tiende a infinito si se
aproxima a 2 tiene una cinta horizontal
en igualados con lo cual esta de aquí
arriba parece ser hdx parece ser hdx y
podemos confirmar esto cuando se hace
hdx igual a 0 bueno cuando el
denominador es 0 y esto ocurre cuando x
es igual a 6 aunque esto en realidad
tampoco nos ayuda mucho porque x también
se hace cero cuando x es igual a 6 así
es que es la cinta horizontal lo que nos
da la clave para distinguir entre hdx y
g x cuando x es cada vez más grande
restar 12 el numerador y 5 el
denominador no va a importar vemos los
términos de mayor orden que son 2x sobre
x con lo cual la función se aproxima a 2
y eso corresponde a h ahora para g
si usamos nuestro razonamiento deductivo
pues esperamos que ésta sea gdx a ver
veamos que de x es igual a 12 menos 2x
sobre x menos 5
ahora cuando x es cada vez más grande
cuando x tiende a infinito tomamos los
términos de mayor orden esto es
aproximadamente igual a menos 2 x sobre
x y esto es cuando existiendo infinito
menos 2 x sobre x es igual a menos 2 o
esto se aproxima a menos 2 que es de
hecho donde se ubica a la sin tota
horizontal de g cuando x es cada vez más
grande que se aproxima a menos dos y
cuando x es cada vez más pequeña que
también se aproxima a menos 2 menos 2 x
menos un billón sobre menos un billón
también va a ser menos 2 con lo cual
podemos confiar que ésta efectivamente
es gd x